everything old is new again and i'm not
exactly thrilled by that
usually i'd put more time between doing
episodes of animation junkie but this is
something i've been meaning to talk
about for a little while now and it's
really
gotten on hand lately and i need to talk
about this and that is
disney remaking their animated features
i've mentioned somewhat offhandedly in
other videos that i am not a big fan
of the idea of taking an animated film
and remaking it
as a live-action movie i don't have a
real substantive argument to make
and that at least that would be any
different from the argument you'd make
against remaking anything again so
really in a lot of ways what it comes
down to is i feel that that
inherently belittles the medium of
animation
i remember back when the first lord of
the rings movies were coming out and the
anticipation was really building and i
was in
an online board and somebody asked the
question why are they starting with the
lord of the rings why wouldn't you do
the hobbit first and one of the things
that i
threw out there is possibly being a
factor was that we already had a
perfectly
serviceable version of the hobbit and
that is the rank and bass animated
version
and pretty much the immediate response
that i got from people was like
yeah that's all fine but i'm talking
about a real movie
and that was really kind of the first
time that it hammered into me that
my notion of holding animation at the
same level
as live action that i do most people
don't now i'm really kind of singling
out disney here because what they're
doing right now specifically
has me really really irritated and if
you haven't been following they
obviously have been doing somewhat
recently a number of
live-action i'm not going to call them
spin-offs but i'll say reinterpretations
of stuff that they had
i suppose you could say it kind of
kicked off with tim burton's alice in
wonderland
there was maleficent and then earlier
this year we had cinderella now it's
really
starting with cinderella that i start to
get annoyed because
alice in wonderland and maleficent while
not necessarily great movies i
understand
why they were made in there you can make
an artistic argument for why they exist
in the case of alice in wonderland they
technically it was a sequel
although it was a weird kind of sequel
where she didn't remember being in
wonderland before the first time so i i
don't know what that was about but
regardless of you have tim burton make
alice in wonderland
and you just kind of go well why
wouldn't you do that that's like all in
his
wheelhouse and i suppose by making it a
sequel instead of a direct adaptation
gave
him the freedom to go you know in a
notably different place than the
original book itself or even
the previous disney animation went i
don't think it worked but he
was allowed that freedom with maleficent
this is obviously a very different
retelling from a different character's
perspective so it's a notably different
story again
did quite work started out strongly lost
steam towards the end but this is not a
review of those movies
in the case of cinderella they pretty
much just did
their animated version again in live
action
now i have to be honest i have not seen
that new version of cinderella i don't
intend to see it but
pretty much all the response has been
very positive people said it was a very
good movie that was better than
maleficent it was better than
alice in wonderland and i i will believe
that i'm not
doubting that but i don't care if it's
better than those
if all they're doing is taking the
animation and doing it again in live
action i understand it's not literally
the same there were minor tweaks to it
cinderella and the prince meet
before the ball once so you know it's
not completely
ridiculous that they fall for each other
on the first view
structurally it's the same movie and i
i've done my research i've done this
i've read the synopsis i've read the
characters it is the same thing with
very very minor tweaks and i just feel
that inherently belittles
not only the original but animation as
an art form because now
people go okay well that's the that's
the kitty version here's the real
version but it's the same
thing and i understand that these are
all adaptations these are not original
stories they weren't the animated film
first these came from source material
and there is a validity
to reinterpreting that source material
to go back to it
and stay true to it take it in a
different direction emphasize a
different aspect of it that was maybe
dropped from the previous film
whatever but that's not what they're
doing that's not what they did with
cinderella and it's not what they appear
to be doing in all the newly announced
features and i can't even remember what
all of them
are anymore but the ones that i can
think of off the top my head there's
beauty and the beast which they've got
mostly cast at this point
they've got the jungle book which i
think comes out next year and they've
since announced
dumbo and winnie the pooh now granted
we're really far away from those ones
but
you cannot tell me that there's any way
they're going to be able to do those
live action without doing
the character of dumbo and the character
of winnie the pooh and all of his
friends
as cgi and as far as i'm concerned cgi
is just animation again so what are you
doing and i think really what set
everything off in the wrong course was
the fact that cinderella succeeded and
it succeeded
with critics and also with audiences
it's done well at the box office
maleficent did decent at the box office
but critics were very divided it wasn't
a
universal acclaim and that was when they
went in a different direction with it
then they came out with the film that
very much stuck to what they did before
and did much better and now it looks
like they're just gonna do that
and this isn't just me speculating on
this because you look at what they've
done and what they've announced
in terms of these films beauty and the
beast is
to be a musical again they haven't
necessarily confirmed they're using the
exact same songs again but
they announced that josh gab is going to
be lefou now lefou
does not come from any version of the
original story of beauty and the beast
lefou is a creation of disney so they
are
not retelling the story of beauty and
the beast they are remaking
their film and the jungle book is
another one because
if there is any story that disney has
done an adaptation of
that you go back to the source material
and there are a million different things
different ways so much stuff that they
dropped so many themes they did not work
with
it's the jungle book there's a lot of
different ways that you could do that
but every indication is that they're
doing it the same to the point that
baloo
is still gonna sing bear necessities
which is iconic not to the story
but to the animated film and i think i
know why
disney is doing this because they can't
do what they used to do
because what they used to do was
re-release the animated films back into
theaters
now for those of you who are on the
younger side are used to a really packed
movie schedule where there's
at least two new movies out every single
weekend that is a pretty recent trend
that was not the norm for a very long
time and there used to be
gaps weeks would go by and there would
be no new films so
older films would get re-released to
theaters and disney
was really the master at this i got to
see things like
101 dalmatians fantasia and peter pan
in the theater despite the fact that all
those movies are older than i am
but they can't do that anymore not only
because there isn't really a gap and an
opening to put in a movie that's already
come out but also because of home video
because the reason they were so
successful doing that is that
home video wasn't really a thing yet
even getting into the late 80s you know
people had vhs's but you they were still
mostly going to rent them not a lot of
people own them now
home media people own these movies they
can watch them whenever they want and i
think that's why
they've kind of eased off the
re-releasing of their animated films in
3d which was the closest they were kind
of coming to that old thing but
i don't think they were seeing the
returns they wanted for that what their
so what they've done instead is
how can we milk more money out of these
things we've already done
well we can remake it again in live
action we don't have to
change anything we'll just do it with
actors and we'll
make all the money and that just drives
me crazy because like i said
not only are they just sort of strip
mining these classics and they are
classics most of these are
classic movies but they're not going
back to the original versions of the
story and coming up with a new
interpretation they are strip mining
their
own stuff and as a lover of animation
that
just inherently belittles what
they did and what they did with these
animated films
is amazing and i don't think there's
anything that we can do to stop this and
i'm not even gonna make the step to say
don't go see these movies because you
know what
the movies will probably be good like i
said every indication was that
cinderella was good
and it probably is but its existence
just
aggravates me on so many levels as a
lover of these movies and as a lover of
animation in general
i just hate this
i hate this trend and i hate that one of
the
giants of animation is leading the way
in belittling the art form that made
them what they are today
and i don't really have much more of a
capper to put on this
i'm just depressed so what about you
what are your thoughts on all of this do
you care do you not was it even on your
radar that this sort of thing was going
on
whatever the case is drop something down
in the comments and let's talk about it
as for me
i'll be back as soon as i can get my
next fix